le malaise sur le tour de france les
auditions se poursuivent comme pour le
directeur sportif et le médecin de
l'équipe festina
bruno roussel est suspendu de ses
fonctions provisoirement mais l'équipe
elle reste dans le tour dans ce journal
nous recevrons jean marie leblanc le
directeur du tour de france
la visite très controversée du président
syrien à paris l'homme n'y était pas
venu depuis 22 ans
l'enjeu le processus de paix au proche
orient la formule choc de charles pasqua
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur propose
purement et simplement de régulariser
tous les sans papiers déjà connus et
puis une page spéciale dans ce journal
une page consacrée au 51ème festival
d'avignon nous retrouverons georges
bégoux sur place avec pierre arditi et
charles berling et enfin nous irons à
hendaye rejoindre bixente lizarazu l'un
des héros de la bande à jacquet qui
retrouve les siens
aujourd'hui madame monsieur bonsoir
toute la journée les auditions de bruno
roussel le directeur sportif de l'équipe
festina ainsi que du médecin se sont
poursuivis au commissariat de cholet
bruno roussel a même été suspendu de ses
fonctions par l'union cycliste
internationale qui est considéré les
faits suffisamment graves et ce soir les
deux hommes sont toujours entendus par
les policiers du srpj de lille tout de
suite le point sur cette enquête qui
pénalise de plus en plus le tour de
france olivier galzi et jean-pierre
pasteur aujourd'hui pas de déclaration à
la sortie de l'hôtel
l'équipe festina visiblement agacé
restée muette
seul le remplaçant de bruno roussel son
adjoint a accepté de nous dire quelques
mots
il avait demandé à 30 ans
des entendu de toute façon hier dès
l'arrivée de la course mais à l'écart de
la foule ou une rousse elle n'a que le
temps de prendre un pull il vient d'être
arrêté par les enquêteurs ni loi
quelques minutes après c'est le médecin
de l'équipe festina qui sera la cible
des policiers perquisitions dans l'hôtel
et discussions dans un car à l'abri des
regards indiscrets et rich rieker ce
sera lui aussi placé en garde à vue ce
soir les deux hommes sont toujours
entendus au commissariat de cholet
il devrait être transféré à lille dans
les heures qui viennent
incontestablement l'étape de demain pour
l'équipe festina sera lilloise une étape
judiciaire qui va conditionner l'avenir
des festina dans ce tour de france 98
car si la responsabilité de
l'encadrement étaient engagés bien le
sponsor lviv pourrait se retirer
soulageante ainsi l'organisation du tour
de france de plus en plus embarrassé par
cette affaire
mais pour l'instant le sponsor de
l'équipe festina qui s'est rendu sur le
tour maintient sa confiance à ses
coureurs il s'en remet à la justice
française
quant à l'équipe elle même à commencer
par richard geerinck pas question
qu'elle se retire du tour même si
l'ambiance est devenue de plus en plus
pesant florent gautreau et alain poirier
elle des coureurs amer pour une journée
particulière les chasseurs d'autographes
sont repartis bredouilles du lui et les
autres n'avaient pas le coeur à ça matin
pluvieux héros malheureux avec la
descente de police effectué hier
l'horizon des festina
c'est encore plus obscure si pour
virenque comme pour ses équipiers les
sourires sont forcés et les signes de
nervosité évident
il s'en fout rien de jouer en famille à
l'écart et loir et chérienne l'étape de
viron commence en effet par un col
difficile à franchir
une conférence de presse devant une
centaine de journalistes y est aussi
offensif derrière les micros que sur un
vélo question de partir comme ça et pour
encore d'informations l'équipe allait
s'arrêter pour un combat sur console et
qui continuera jusqu'en l'an 2000
orpheline de bruno roussel l'équipe a
commencé une nouvelle course presque une
nouvelle vie rarement aux avant-postes
virenque et ses coéquipiers sont restés
discrets pourtant sur le bord de la
route
le public a pris fait et cause pour
festina et pour son leader affaire
festina ou pas des habitués du tour
reste fidèle à l'équipe française
je pense j'espère qu'ils vont pas
abandonner d'après de prendre les gens à
venir mais avant un soutien populaire
qui met sans doute du baume au coeur des
coureurs fortement perturbé depuis
quelques jours être ou ne pas être sur
le tour c'est la question pour festina
le seul à pouvoir décider du retrait de
l'équipe c'est le patron de festina
miguel rodriguez
on avait annoncé sa venue aujourd'hui
sur le tour et personne ne l'a vu pour
l'instant virenque et ses coéquipiers
sont donc toujours en course et l'
affaire festina est évoquée par lionel
jospin aujourd'hui le premier ministre
qui estime que les conclusions de ce
dossier doivent être tirées
j'ai vu avec tristesse
pa je dois dire avec une totale surprise
parce qu'on pouvait avoir des motifs
d'inquiétude
des informations selon lequelles et des
gens sans scrupules
vous les fournir à des cyclistes est
sûrement fournissait des produits
dopants
interdit naturellement difficile ou
impossible à déceler et en même temps
certainement très dangereux pour la
santé de ces sportifs leur santé
d'aujourd'hui ou leur santé de demain
est donc ainsi que l'a dit marie-george
buffet la ministre de la jeunesse et des
sports il au bas de ce point de vue que
toute la lumière soit sur les réalités
et que les conclusions soient tirées çà
sera l'attitude du gouvernement une
attitude de transparence qui est
particulièrement nécessaire dans ce
domaine alors avec nous jean marie
leblanc le directeur du tour de france
merci à vous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
vous avez entendu lionel jospin il ya
des conclusions à tirer immédiatement de
ce qui se passe sur le tour bien entendu
et nous espérons tous sur le tour de
france que ces conclusions
interviendront le plus tôt possible plus
vite possible pour comment dirais-je
pour permettre de france de retrouver
son atmosphère sa crédibilité son
ambiance son authenticité sportive
alors s'il reste que ces conclusions
interviendront autour d'hommes qui sont
j'irai périphériques à la compétition
puisque pour ce qui concerne les
coureurs eux-mêmes il a été dit et
répété qu'ils n'ont jusqu'à preuve du
contraire pas commis d'infraction et peu
et que par conséquent ils ne sont
passibles d'aucune sanction
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous
partageons la position de l'équipe des
coureurs de l'équipe festina de vouloir
continuer la course ça veut dire que
vous attendrez d'éventuelles décisions
judiciaires il n'est pas question pour
vous de prendre une sanction sportive a
priori et de demander à l'équipe par
exemple de quitter le tour pas question
dans les sanctions sportives entrées ont
été déjà prises par ceux qui en ont la
responsabilité c'est à dire les
dirigeants de l'union cycliste
internationale qui se sont prononcés
sévèrement me semble-t-il est justement
qui à la lecture du dossier ont décidé
de suspendre bruno celle de sa licence
de ses fonctions et même de toute
fonction dans le cyclisme
jusqu'à ce que ses conclusions soient
connues mais les enquêtes judiciaires on
le sait sont souvent longues alors est
ce que la situation des festina sion le
coup sûr le tour ne risque pas d'être de
plus en plus difficile au fil des jours
il il est vraisemblable que les coureurs
de l'équipe festina richard virenque
alex du lait et leurs copains on était
sont en situation morale difficile et il
me semble cependant que depuis
aujourd'hui
depuis qu en quelque sorte l'abcès a été
crevé leur moral est meilleur et se sont
serré les coudes ils ont affirmé tous
ensemble ce matin qu'il voulait
continuer la compétition et la réussir
si possible je crois que c'est un
comportement champions c'est un
comportement qui les honore c'est un
comportement que
public reconnaît d'ailleurs nous avons
vu sur le bord de la route aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'encouragements pour l'équipe
festina
je crois que je répète jusqu'à preuve du
contraire il ne faut pas perturber la le
comportement sportif de ses athlètes
alors je mens et le blanc avant de
continuer je vous propose de voir un
portage n'est bien sûr pas la première
fois que l'ombre du dopage plane sur le
tour alors voyons si vous voulez bien
avec christelle bertrand quelles sont
ses précédents on l'appelle aujourd'hui
l' affaire festina
c'est la première fois que le dopage est
sur la ligne de départ du tour de france
avant les coureurs et si les contrôles
existent depuis 1966 c'est qu'il y avait
des doutes bien avant en 66 justement
les coureurs apprennent qu'ils seront
contrôlés ils font grève mais repartent
la nécessité des contrôles s'impose
l'année suivante dans le dernier
kilomètre tom simpson s'effondre pendant
l'ascension du mont ventoux simpson
titube et remis en selle plusieurs fois
mais il meurt d'un oedème pulmonaire
il a pris des stupéfiants
en 77 et 79 iozzo tenait été contrôlé
positif aux anabolisants en 77 c'est la
première fois que ce genre de produits
est contrôlée hotmail qu est le premier
attrapé 1988 le dopage touche le futur
vainqueur du tour pedro delgado à 10
urines positive il se défend comme il
peut maintenant débuter dès lors le
public pense que les publics le succès
ne sont pas des personnes mauvaise
delgado est positif aux pros béni s'il
se produit masquer la présence
d'anabolisants et les retient dans
l'organisme
mais il ne figure pas sur la liste des
produits interdits par l'union cycliste
internationale delgado ne sera jamais
sanctionnés
en 91 le phénomène prend de l'ampleur la
suspicion ne se porte plus sur un
coureur mais sur une équipe toute
entière mais pdm déclare forfait et se
retire du tour pour une mystérieuse
épidémie de grippe la grippe est un
symptôme de prise de p o
les contrôles antidopage sur le tour de
france sont de plus en plus précis mais
il semble qu'en matière de dopage
les coureurs ont encore une longueur
d'avancé
alors jean marie leblanc et soudaine a
le sentiment d'avoir fait tout ce qu'il
y avait à faire en matière de contrôle
de pêche beaucoup plus généralement est
ce que les autorités du cyclisme elles
mêmes font ce qu'il faut quand on voit
par exemple que delgado reste champion
après avoir été contrôlé positif même si
les règles n'étaient pas tout à fait les
mêmes
j'ai le sentiment que les autorités font
tout ce qu'elles peuvent tout ce
qu'elles doivent et que ce sont les
autorités du cyclisme qui les premières
ont entamé la lutte contre le dopage
après la mort de simpson nous l'avons vu
en 1967
c'est en effet en 68 l'année suivante et
personnellement j'étais dans ce tour de
france que les contrôles ont été
instaurées et depuis ces contrôles anti
dopage n'ont jamais cessé
sachez par exemple que en ce moment tous
les jours six coureurs six sont soumis
au contrôle anti dopage par l'inspecteur
médical de l'union cycliste
internationale et nous aurons je crois
dans les prochains jours que car nous
organisateurs nous l'avons demandé des
tests sanguins comme il y en a eu l'an
dernier comme il y en a maintenant dans
les grandes compétitions et ce sont là
encore les autorités cycliste qui
l'année dernière ont demandé les
premières que des tests sanguins soit
effectué sur les coureurs alors il me
semble que et si j'ajoute et part donc
au plan français
la fédération française de cyclisme est
en train d'instaurer un suivi médical
permanent pour tous les athlètes
je ne crois pas que le cyclisme soit en
retard en la matière jean mais le bilan
reste est resté avec nous nous avons sur
le plateau le professeur jean paul
escande inquiets donc professeur bonjour
vous avez été pendant six ans je crois
le président de la commission nationale
de lutte contre le dopage le dopage
quel est ce fameux produit le p o dont
on parle beaucoup et bien sûr ses
conséquences et ses dangers
l'érythropoïétine c'est pas du tout un
produit qui agit sur le sens comme
j'entends dire c'est un produit qui agit
sur la moelle osseuse
quand on mange du pot-au-feu ya des eaux
avec de la moelle c'est cette moelle qui
fabrique les globules et à l'intérieur
de la moelle osseuse à des cellules qui
fabriquent les globules rouges
or les riques trop héritera ça veut dire
rouge pour y est in c'est à dire
produire six produits les globules
rouges une molécule qui vient dans la
moelle osseuse panel moelle épinière
pour faire fabriquer plus de globules
rouges et quand on a plus de globules
rouges
on a une grande réserve d'oxygène et ça
sert effectivement dans tous les sports
je connais sur le blanc que fit brive et
que je souhaite une bonne arrivée à
brive demain ou un compatriote sauront
dire bonjour de passe comme il convient
à ce que j'ai l'impression que tout est
fait comme le dit monsieur leblanc pour
lutter contre le le dopage écoutez moi
je voudrais je pense que le dopage est
une plaie et j'ai souvent dit que l'âge
d'or du sport et en particulier du sport
télévisé pouvait s'interrompre du fait
du dopage
je crois qu'on n'a pas toujours très
bien compris ce que je voulais dire et
j'ai peur d'avoir raison aujourd'hui
mais il est vrai que ce serait une
vraiment très grande méchanceté de faire
porter tout le poids du dopage et sur le
tour de france et sur le cyclisme il n'y
a pas que des brebis blanche dans le
milieu du cyclisme mais les brebis
noires ne sont pas toutes dans le
cyclisme peut le dire mais il est vrai
que les responsables du tour de france
ont fait des efforts dans le cadre de la
loi donc il faut modifier les lois s'il
en train d'être fait et il faut que le
mouvement sportif dans son ensemble
fasse un effort et on ne peut pas dire
que le tour de france soit à la traîne
de ce côté là on peut pas nous jean
marie leblanc vous êtes vous d'accord ce
discours est prêt à ce que les pensées
que les joueurs sont prêts à se
soumettre à des contrôles de plus en
plus dur quitte à ce qu'on ne lie j'ai
l'impression qu'on les suspecte
constamment quand on les traque qu'on
les suspecte
ils ont tout de même déjà donné des
gages de coopération mais je voudrais
ajouter ceci les coureurs s'attaquer au
corps c'est bien mais il faudrait
s'attaquer aussi aux pourvoyeurs aux
médecins marron au chimiste qui mettent
sur le marché
tous ces produits prohibés
et ce n'est pas en bout de course le
coureur le consommateur le lampiste en
quelque sorte qui est seule responsable
moi je partage l'opinion de madame la
ministre des sports d'un buffet qui a
déclaré depuis toujours et nous sommes
complètement d'accord que il faut aussi
traqué les pourvoyeurs les dealers lé là
le jaune et le plan mais il faut aussi
balayé dans le sport il faut aussi
balayé dans le sport parce que si vous
voulez moi je vais vous dire une chose
toute simple
le jour où je vois un soigneur venir me
dire qu'est ce que je peux dire à mes
gars pour qu'ils aient moins peur de
prendre ce qu'on leur donne
il faut pas non plus nier ça donc si
vous voulez je vous rends hommage pour
ce que vous faites mais je crois qu'il
ne faut pas être trop vite
moi comme vous auto satisfaits de ce que
nous avons fait parce que manifestement
- comme vous nous avons relativement
échoué donc il faut refaire autre chose
monsieur leblanc et d'animaux et puis
nous se planque de doctorat de kleenex
oui oui je suis d'accord avec le
professeur escompte bien entendu bien
entendu il ne faut pas être manichéen et
pour le choix d'un côté et les noirs de
l'autre côté les blancs non ma
conclusion si vous permettez ce serait
de dire que maintenant que les choses
ont été explicitées et à les commenter
et est maintenant que la justice va
suivre son cours je crois qu'il faut
aussi que le tour de france puisse
suivre son cours quand on peut pas
imaginer qu'il y ait dans le tour de
france 170 coureurs dopés
nous allons aborder après demain une
étape décisive contre la montre en
corrèze il y aura tout aussitôt les
pyrénées le public sera là il ya des
compétiteurs me motive et nous les avons
vus place au sport en quelque sorte
maintenant alors merci à cordes et donc
cette interview pendant ce journal merci
à vous professeurs et puis heureusement
donc maintenant donc à la compétition
elle même avec cette 5e étape entre
cholet et châteauroux l'italien mario
cipollini a retrouvé son statut de grand
maître du sprint en s'imposant à
l'arrivée
le fanion voir que granby conserve son
maillot jaune malgré une chute au km 80
il souffre vous allez le voir d'une
contusion à la hanche qui ne l'empêchera
pas malgré tout de prendre le départ
demain voilà cette fameuse chute et dans
cette chute un autre le power a été plus
sérieusement touché au bassin il
souffrirait d'une fracture au bassin
c'est l'italien silvio martinel l'os et
qui lui ne pourra bien sûr pas repartir
demain en football après les bleus
d'aimé jacquet c'est au tour des
organisateurs de la coupe du monde de
football d'être à l'honneur mais ça fait
long le président du c est faux le
comité français d'organisation a donc
été reçu avec son staff par lionel
jospin à matignon pour être félicités
lors de ses différents contacts qui sont
4 me a pu dire que si jacques chirac
aimait les sportifs et bien lieu les
jospin lui et mais plutôt le sport et
puis en marge de cette coupe du monde
sachez que le dernier des trois
hooligans arrêtés ces jours ci en
allemagne a été à son tour mis en examen
pour l'agression contre le gendarme
daniel nivel la police le présentent
comme le suspect numéro un dans cette
tentative de meurtre et nous allons tout
de suite à hendaye après les retours au
pays de fabien barthez d'emmanuel petit
yeah eh bien c'est au tour de bixente
lizarazu de retrouver les siens alors
bixente bonsoir ça fait du bien de
retrouver son pays j'imagine ça fait du
bien ça fait du bien c'est vrai mais on
se connaît pas froid tous les joueurs à
un accueil comme ça et c'est magnifique
on revient chez soi on revoit toute sa
famille ses amis il ya toute son enfance
qui défilent et ewen un hommage bon on
se rend compte de l'importance à coupe
du monde dans ces moments là alors on va
voir s'ils voulaient bien les images
justement de votre votre retour vous
allez les commenter avec nous je crois
qu'il ya votre père qui a qui a chanté
en basque c'est ça pour en votre honneur
ouais voilà il ya eu leur rescousse et
un hommage basque ensuite il ya eu
trois chambres deux chorales parce que
j'adore la chorale et mon père voilà je
suis avec mon premier entraîneur de club
de mon fils l'équipe minime dans
laquelle vous jouez vos eglantins les
eglantins mandat et en étant un bon club
dans lequel j'ai débuté ici on sait pas
trop difficile de supporter cette
pression là mais vous avez besoin de
quoi maintenant de vacances ouais bon on
a besoin de calme de tranquillité mais
je crois que quand on gagne du monde le
sait c'est pas c'est pas un sésame
henrard pour pour accepter toutes ces
sollicitations et encore plus dans sa
ville d'origine
mais ce que l'équipe de france ne vous
manque pas trop quand même en vue non
dans le sens où on a démarré une
aventure on l'a terminé on a été au bout
on est champion du monde et ça fait ça
c'est du bien de l'être quoi on va
apprécier toute notre vie et je crois qu
si à chaque fois qu'on va se voir les 22
puis le staff
il ya plein de moments magiques qui vont
revenir dans nos têtes bon et puis vous
avez quand même là devant vous un petit
peu de quelques jours de récupération
avant d'attaquer le fougueux imagine way
n'est pas suffisamment à mon goût je
dois reprendre début août avec le bayern
mais bien on rentre dans l'est je dirais
l'aspect professionnel c'est à dire que
les clubs ont besoin de nous et on se
doit de répondre à ses sollicitations
donc moi je vais devoir rentrer le 1er
août
bon allez vite vous reposer surtout
cette belle région qu'est le quel pays
basque et merci oui pour cette belle
cette belle coupe du monde que vous nous
avez tous ceux offerts l'autre grand
dossier du jour c'est bien sûr l'arrivée
du président syrien à paris une visite
pour le moins délicate sinon controversé
hafez el assad n'est pas à proprement
parler un démocrate
on l'a surnommé le bismarck du proche
orient pour son habileté à s'imposer
toujours comme un partenaire obligé pour
toute solution politique dans la région
philippe rochot et j'ai encore dû il ne
sort guère de son pays et il aime à dire
que ce sont les gens qui se dérangent
pour venir le voir
si hafez el-assad a fait le voyage c'est
qu'il parie sur la france et sur l'union
européenne pour sortir de son isolement
briser le monopole américain sur les
négociations de paix qui sont dans
l'impasse
une visite d'état pour laquelle la
france ne ménage pas ses efforts
assad venu avec cinq ministres une
délégation importante d'hommes
d'affaires rencontrera près de la moitié
des membres du gouvernement français
quand il est venu la dernière fois en 76
jacques chirac était premier ministre
et à l'époque la politique irakienne de
la france gêné quelque peu nos rapports
avec la syrie aujourd'hui la france
relance sa diplomatie au proche orient
face à l'impasse des négociations et la
syrie cherche un autre partenaire que
washington
mes visites peu tranquille à l'heure des
entretiens serge et béate klarsfeld eux
manifestent pour p damas livre aloïs
brunner responsable de la déportation et
donc de la mort de plus de cent trente
mille juifs hafez el-assad a pourtant
nié hier la présence de brûlures sur le
territoire syrien
jacques chirac est conscient que le
parcours de la syrie n'est pas sans
faute qu'elle maintient 30000 soldats au
liban qu'elle détient plusieurs
centaines de prisonniers politiques mais
elle ne doit pas rester isolé au cours
du dîner qui va commencer dans un
instant avec quelques 200 invités
jacques chirac rappellera hafez el-assad
le rôle essentiel que la france et la
syrie peuvent jouer pour une relance du
processus de paix au proche orient avec
notamment l'idée franco égyptienne d'une
nouvelle conférence de la paix à
laquelle la syrie participerait
activement les échanges se multiplient
entre la france et la syrie petit à
petit il est un domaine dans lequel il
remporte beaucoup de succès notamment
auprès des jeunes c'est bien sûr la mode
une école de mode s'est même installé à
damas et alep et quand on connaît le
poids des traditions dans les pays
musulmans
c'est un véritable parc le reportage en
syrie de philippe rochot et de jacques
gérard fanlo foulard et femme vêtu à
l'occidentale se croisent indifférente
dans les rues de damas al'inverse du
reste du monde musulman les tenues à la
mode lan porte aujourd'hui sur le voile
et les vêtements islamiques
la mode est une forme d'évasion qui
ouvre aux créateurs les portes de la
syrie
une école esmod s'est installé ici
attirant des couturières qui porte
encore le foulard mais provoquant aussi
la curiosité des parents pour les
vêtements du futur de leurs enfants des
dossiers où l'on trouve des saints
écoute s'inspirant de la culture arabe
comme ce projet que réalise lara et
l'utilisent les dessins géométriques et
les couleurs des maisons de la cire en
arabie pour composer son modèle en
harmonie avec la mode internationale
coppi ce qui existe déjà dans le souk
donc ils ont une vue des tendances
internationales
donc il s'inspire déjà des tendances et
après comme c'est une collection
personnelle au forcément leur culture
ressortent quelques pas et donc ils
mélangent un petit peu la mode
internationale l heure
160 étudiants suivent ainsi les cours de
l'école de mode franco-syrienne un
débouché naturel pour des familles qui
vivent souvent du textile en syrie mais
difficile parfois de faire entrer dans
les moeurs traditionnel l'idée de
vêtements jugés provoquant les
conservatismes dans le monde arabe ne
sont pas faciles à vaincre des fois les
annonces âge ne pas le porter parce que
c'est trop dénudées trop transparents ou
le petit copain diallo il n'est pas
question que tu portes ça où tu ne
défilera pas avec ça donc ça nous pose
quelques problèmes pour préparer le
défilé
car cette mode va se montrer pour la
première fois dans l'un des plus beaux
caravansérail de damas les élèves de
l'école de mode franco-syrienne
préparent leur premier défilé
trente six mannequins à qu'il faut
d'abord apprendre à marcher mais dans un
pays quelque peu fermé au reste du monde
la mode a réussi une percée
incontestable en algérie treize
personnes ont été assassinées deux
autres blessés la nuit dernière près de
tiaret à 240 km au sud ouest d'alger
cette nouvelle tuerie est imputée par
les autorités au groupe armé islamique
c'est presque le monde à l'envers dans
une interview au journal le monde
charles pasqua propose purement et
simplement de régulariser tous les
sans-papiers identifié y compris ceux
dont les dossiers ont donc été rejetée
ce qui veut dire à peu près 70 mille
personnes une solution surprise de la
part de l'auteur de la fameuse loi
pasqua sur l'immigration jean baptiste
près dali et vincent foucart
certains risquent de ne plus s'y
retrouver leur charles pasqua
jusqu'à présent l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur prône l immigration zéro
peser voter des lois restrictives et
tenait un discours musclé mais
aujourd'hui une interview dans le
journal le monde et c'est la surprise
sinon la volte face charles pasqua veut
désormais la régularisation de tous les
sans papiers il faut pas continuer à
entretenir une certaine hypocrisie
il faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont sûres ne peut pas les expulser
il y a une seule solution allemand il
faut pas régulariser ceux qui ont commis
des délits autres ont reçu l'aide est
rentré clandestinement sur notre
territoire mais les autres on ne peut
que les régulariser c'est le commentaire
de jean-pierre chevènement aujourd'hui
monsieur pasqua s'amuse mais les
déclarations de son prédécesseur plaques
vous étonne à gauche et à droite
la déclaration de charles pasqua va à
contre courant de tout ce que nous avons
fait de souche qui l'a fait lui-même
pendant des décennies je suis satisfait
qu'il souhaite maintenant intégré par
une démarche de régularisation de
nombreux sans-papiers
faut-il néanmoins qu'il aille aussi loin
sadran sa démarche suspecte
au passage charles pasqua prend le
contre-pied des positions plus fermes
exprimé par jacques chirac le 14 juillet
l'ex ministre de l'intérieur dit vouloir
créer un électrochoc sur l'immigration
c'est un effet du mondial il est plutôt
surprenant quels seront les produits
visés par une baisse éventuelle de la
tva c'est la question que se pose le
gouvernement l'exercice est difficile
compte tenu des règles très strictes
imposées par bruxelles mais éléments de
réponse avec damien thévenot et jean
francois monier on n'y pense pas
forcément
et pourtant s'il vous plaît est ce que
vous savez vous êtes en train de payer
une partie de vos impôts justes ou
injustes une chose est sûre la tva y
partout 26 % c'est le taux normal
quelques rares produits ne sont
toutefois taxées qu'à 5 5%
l'alimentation par exemple le parti
socialiste suggère une baisse de la tva
dans certains secteurs la restauration
la réclament depuis longtemps
si on met à 14% regret tout de suite
vous aimez la voix et al gore en 2000
année après on va revenir
cette baisse n'est toutefois pas acquis
pour le ministère des finances la tva
c'est la poule aux oeufs d'or 637
milliards de francs pour 98 c'est
beaucoup plus que l'impôt sur le revenu
ou l'impôt sur les sociétés autre
problème la france a adopté une
directive européenne en 92 directive qui
liste le nombre de produits pouvant
bénéficier d'un taux réduit de tva pour
laquelle il faudrait il à modifier ceci
peut être faire avec une proposition de
la commission et à condition que le
texte soit adopté à l'unanimité par les
ministres de chaque état membre
quels produits seront finalement visé
par la baisse de la tva le gouvernement
donnera sa réponse mercredi en conseil
des ministres c'est peut-être une
conséquence du dernier sommet franco
allemand pour la première fois dans les
conflits qui opposent des couples franco
allemands en instance de divorce sur la
garde de leurs enfants
la justice allemande donne raison à une
mère française
mais tout n'est pas réglé puisque le
père à l'annoncé de la nouvelle s'est
enfui avec les enfants olivier lerner et
vincent lumière les coupes
franco allemand qui se déchire les rapts
d'enfants qui en découlent
catherine urban à 60 dossier entre les
mains dont celui de causette lancelin
avec qui elle parle tous les jours au
téléphone
mathias et caroline enlevées par leur
père allemand devrait en principe être
rendus à leurs mères en france 11 en
mariage puis une séparation mal vécue
par le mari le 28 mars dernier sur une
petite route du loir et cher
six hommes recrutés par le père monte
une véritable opération commando pour
enlever les enfants à leur mère en
france
les tribunaux ont donné la garde des
enfants à la mère avis contraire en
allemagne d'appel en appel les allemands
ont finalement fait marche arrière
mais le père et nice depuis hier il a
pris la fuite avec ses enfants qu'il
fait savoir aujourd'hui qu'il porte la
paire akale chaud devant la cour
constitutionnelle mais maintenant il a
un coût et que ce qu'en font les
guideront les enfants et les vendre mais
cette fois ci l'a connu en allemagne qui
lui est la procédure peut durer deux ans
j'ai qu'une idée c'est retrouver le nom
après ils s'arrangent entre étant trop
peu d'issues 10 hier entre entre
magistrats mais qu'on met les enfants à
l'abri sans harmonie sans respect des
conventions ces histoires d'amour qui
tourne mal deviennent des affaires
d'état à état entre la france et
l'allemagne sans solution et puis
dernier coup de théâtre dans cette
affaire la cour constitutionnelle
allemande vient de suspendre cette
décision jusqu'au 3 août décision qui
était donc favorable à la mère française
deux ans après le viol et l'assassinât
de caroline dickinson la jeune
britannique dans une auberge pleine
fougères les autorités judiciaires se
sont réunis sur le terrain pour faire le
point de leur enquête en présence des
parents olivier sioux et michel hiver
accompagné des enquêteurs et de son
avocat français john dickinson visite
l'auberge de jeunesse de saint lunaire
où avait eu lieu une autre agression le
jour même du meurtre de sa fille depuis
le début de l' affaire le père de
caroline a toujours été très présent
dans le déroulement de l'enquète c'était
important pour moi de voir les lieux
l'extérieur mais surtout l'intérieur
pour me forger ma propre opinion
pour cette visite est celle de la
cellule caroline le juge van ruymbeke
n'a pas hésité à dénigrer une commission
rogatoire spéciale signe de la confiance
qui règne aujourd'hui entre les deux
hommes
car depuis la désignation du nouveau
magistrat instructeur il ya un an les
choses se sont accélérées tests
génétiques tous azimuts et recoupements
systématique 3000 personnes ont été
interrogées
une vingtaine sont encore recherchées
nous avons fait un gros travail
effectivement de collationnement de
renseignements que nous exploitons
aujourd'hui et je pense que dans les
mois à venir nous devrions voir le
résultat de ce travail
mais ce qui inquiète aujourd'hui les
enquêteurs c'est le profil psychologique
de certaines des personnes interrogées
lankais a révélé un nombre
impressionnant de gens qui présentent ce
lundi sur le plan sexuel une certaine
dangerosité
on s'interroge de temps en temps et on
se dit on se dit celui-là lâché dans bon
on sait pas ce qui pourrait devenir
certes lé enquête sur le meurtre avec
caroline n'a pas encore abouti né dans
une toute autre affaire elle a permis
d'identifier le violeur d'une fillette
et pour le père de caroline c'est déjà
un réconfort
j'en suis extrêmement heureux sont la
famille concernée et j'ai confiance car
je pense que les tests adn menés dans
toute la france permettront maintenant
d'appréhender de tels individus
magistrats et gendarmes en sont
convaincus il approche du but et c'est
pourquoi john dickinson est venue en
france une nouvelle fois lancé un appel
à témoins alors que l'anc est entre dans
sa troisième année
c'est sans doute l'un des plus grands
événements russie depuis longtemps de
par sa portée symbolique
les dépouilles du dernier tsar de russie
nicolas ii et de la famille impériale
sont arrivés tout à l'heure à
saint-pétersbourg pour y être enterré
ce doit être l'occasion d'une
réconciliation nationale sur cette page
noire de l'histoire russe
le massacre de toute la famille
impériale en 1917 par les bolcheviks
gilles rabin et franck brisé
finalement c'est l'héritière de l'armée
rouge gré par lénine juste avant
l'exécution de nicholas 2 qui a su
rendre un vrai hommage au dernier des
arts
alors que ses funérailles officielles
ont déchaîné toutes les passions en
russie à tel point que les cérémonies
ont été réduites au minimum
après le refus du patriarche orthodoxe
d'y participer et le désistement de
l'ensemble des responsables politiques
s'il restait peu de choses des fastes du
un empereur l'émotion était là
c'est un cycle de l'histoire russe qui
se termine cette cérémonie de
funérailles a une importance vitale pour
quiconque veut être honnête
l'église a ses raisons que je ne discute
pas vous comprenez je suis un officier
qui ne peut pas discuter les ordres du
général mais l'officier il a aussi un
coeur l'église orthodoxe a sans doute
sous-estimé la soif de morale politique
et de justice historique de ses ouailles
et même de ces prêts et c'est peut-être
aussi pourquoi boris elstine nuit a
décidé in extremis de venir demain le
temps de la cérémonie c'est un grand a
repris rostropovitch il la donne et
l'émotion du simple public était aussi
un pense des gens du peuple qui
découvraient les derniers romanov vivant
ce qui sent la révolution bolchevique
aurait été aujourd'hui leur prince et la
princesse gilles rabin vous disaient
certains aussi conteste toujours
l'authenticité de ces dépouilles à
commencer par le patriarche de toutes
les russies
mais les restes du tsar de sa femme
alexandra et de leurs trois filles sont
bien portées en terre demain seul
manquera le petit tsarévitch son corps
lui n'a jamais été retrouvés gilles
rabin et franprix c
c'est l'une des très rares séquences où
l'on peut voir jouer des enfants du
dernier tsar de russie nicolas ii
quatre filles et un garçon en vacances
quelque part au sud de l' empire
alexis des tarés vite l'enfant adoré
anastasia l'espiègle qui trouve toujours
à rire de tout maria la paix d'où sa
soeur préférée du thar évite pas cana
qui se cache la plus élégante la
préférée de sa mère l'impératrice
alexandra et olga nenê qui aiment les
livres la solitude et joue
merveilleusement du piano autre séquence
rares ne tarit vite sautent à terre
comme un enfant normal comme un enfant
en bonne santé pendant dix ans le tsar
nicolas ii et la tsarine alexandra on
espérait un garçon et ont vu naître
l'une après l'autre quatre filles
l'impératrice en devenait hystérique
enfin né alexis et on découvre que
l'enfant était mon fils son sang ne
coagule pas la moindre blessure peut
signer pendant des semaines
l'enfant est faible très vite il faut le
porter
très vite il devient évident pour tous
que cet enfant là ne pourra pas renier
même si chacun la cour et semblant de
l'ignorer
on faisait le buzz mais à l'époque
arrivée en faux apparaît alors
raspoutine un moine illuminés qui gagne
la confiance de l'impératrice parce
qu'elle croit qu'il a le pouvoir de
stopper les hémorragies de son l'emprise
de raspoutine devient telle que nicolas
2 ne décide plus de rien sans son amie
la courbe ans et s'amuse encore mais la
famille impériale est de plus en plus
isolés coupés des réalités du pays est
affaibli tout est en place pour la
tragédie finale
nous partons maintenant pour avignon et
notre page spéciale sur le 51e festival
georges les goûts vous trouvez je crois
dans la cour d'honneur du palais des
papes une un endroit mythique avec pas
loin de vos charles berling qui jouent
dans cette fameuse coup et puis pierre
arditi la cuvée et 98 de ce festival a
paraît-il des accents asiatiques
oui évidemment parce que c'est un
festival planétaire avignon vous avez
ici les troupes de viennent de tous les
continents et vous avez par exemple des
troupes qui viennent de corée qui joue
actuellement devant sur le parvis du
palais des papes
nous pouvons les voir il y a également
des troupes qui viennent de pékin
l'opéra de pékin qui va donner sa pièce
maîtresse le roi singe et nous aurons et
nous en reparlerons plus tard des
marionnettes taïwanaise assez
extraordinaire alors nous avons parlé de
charles berling
il est là effectivement et il est dans
son décor parce que ils jouent ici un
rôle qu'il est vraiment un rôle de poids
oedipe alors ça vous fait peur il ya ces
murailles et puis il ya aussi toute
cette mythologie
oui c'est vrai que c'est des pièces où
tout est réuni pour pour être
impressionnant et en même temps c'est le
fondement du théâtre c'est à dire des
rôles aussi fort et aussi impressionnant
que ça dans un endroit qui a accueilli
tant de grands acteurs de grands de
grand spectacle c'est c'est une secte
c'est très impressionnant mais je pense
que le théâtre est là pour réinventer à
chaque fois les choses on doit pas être
passéiste alors dans ce sens là on est
très heureux d'être ici on essaye de se
battre tous les soirs on va vous on va
vous voir dans un extrait très
emblématique de la fin mais si on te dit
pas les yeux crevés qu'il fait à sa
repentance
paris vers marseille et du père on ne
m'aurait pas appeler les bouts de kima
rampante et je suis maintenant dans la
douleur fils de 5000 aise et de même
lignée que ceux dont je proviens avoir
pauvre s'il existe un mal originel il
l'a reçue et div
voilà une critique assez chagrine a
reproché un petit peu à cette mise en
scène d'être statique
or vous vouliez défendre le texte nous
on défend jean louis martinelli a fait
une mise en scène volontairement très
épuré dans le sens que on défend le
théâtre on défend le texte le théâtre
comme un geste qui a qui associé à du
texte à un espace des spas sicié très
beau et on n'a pas voulu faire des
tonnes d'effets pour faire passer ça
mais au contraire cherché à faire
quelque chose qui soit dans la pure
lignée du théâtre c'est à dire des
acteurs un texte et un espace absolument
sublime et je crois qu'on voit bien que
tous les soirs les spectateurs sont son
prix est mû par ça mais il faut pas
rendre le théâtre il faut pas il faut
pas faire du théâtre une chose qui skie
qui veut absolument se vendre le plus
facilement possible au contraire il faut
et il faut que le théâtre garde une
force de conviction qui qu'il puise même
dans sa complexité
alors vous êtes jeune vous faites du
cinéma là est ce qu'on peut dire que
eudis de sophocle c'est un texte qui
peut toucher les jeunes bien entendu
enfin en tout cas si je sais que c'est
ce sont des textes quand quand on les
répète qui vous qui vous happe qui vous
prennent qui vous mangez et qui ont des
qui sont absolument pas des textes comme
ça d'une culture oublié mais au
contraire qu'ils sont extrêmement vivant
à l'intérieur de soi et je je je peux
vous dire que jean pâtit tous les soirs
d'une certaine manière parce que c'est
des c'est quelque chose qui comme comme
on dit dans la pièce qui n'a pas rêvé de
coucher avec sa mère et qui n'a pas
voulu tuer son père c'est cdc un rapport
à ça qui est extrêmement fins et très
puissants comme texte bon donc vous vous
êtes dans le plus grand espace théâtral
d'avignon là nous allons nous rendre
le plus petit dans un castelet de
marionnettes avec ses fameuses
marionnettes taïwanaise et vous allez
voir ces manipulateurs extraordinaire
petit prologue pour mettre en évidence
la disproportion entre l'humain et la
marionnette
dans le cadre argent et or d'un castelet
en forme de pagode se déroule une action
complexe où le personnage principal est
confronté en un voyage initiatique à
toutes les formes de combat
comme dans tout les guignols du monde de
la bagarre il y en a
il faut quelquefois se transformer en
oiseau pour amadouer le dragon la
performance du marionnettiste atteint
des sommets à la fin du spectacle les
enfants ont le plaisir de manipuler à
leur tour ils rêvent sans doute d'être
un virtuose comme roucoule le benjamen
l'équipe
beaubourg nous restons à avignon avec
george v ou bien sûr qu'ils arrivent
vers vous pierre arditi pierre et qui
bon soir vous êtes avignon pour une
lecture d'une jeune auteure à noëlle
renaude et puis la dernière fois qu'on
vous a vu à l'antenne c'était pour
parler de d'aimé jacquet que pour
prendre sa défense et vous avez bien
raison oui vous trouvez non mais je je
pensais simplement qui a vous savez dans
la vie et deux catégories de gens les
gens qui commentent et pourquoi pas il
ya des gens qui font alors je préfère la
seconde catégorie j'espère appartenir à
cette catégorie là que je n'aimais pas
le ton qu'on employait pour parler de ce
monsieur d'ailleurs visiblement il sait
pas tellement trompé puisque la france
est championne du monde
il a fait un travail de fond c'est à
dire qu'il a créé un groupe et une
mentalité qui est tout à fait
particulière qui d'ailleurs rejaillit
sur l'ensemble de notre vie aujourd'hui
en particulier par rapport à un certain
discours nous connaissions parle plus
longtemps du mondial c'est carton jaune
c'est fini bon alors vous êtes là pour
une lecture ma solange comment t'écrire
mon désastre accéderont oui ça vous dire
sur les auteurs vivants oui je bats
c'est dire que non je défends je défends
bien sûr des fonds des auteurs vivants
je pense que on entend toujours dire
qu'il n'ya plus d'auteurs que le théâtre
est mort en réalité évidemment il ya des
auteurs il ya les auteurs qu'on n'entend
pas ou peu ou en tout cas beaucoup trop
beau et on peut pas passer son temps à
faire du théâtre vivant avec des auteurs
mort non pas qu'il ne faille pas monter
underlines berline c'est passionnant
c'est magnifique et puis il ya des voix
d'aujourd'hui des voix contemporaines
qu'on entend encore une fois beaucoup
trop peu alors je participe avec la s à
céder sous l'impulsion de jean michel
ribes à ces lectures d'auteurs
contemporains vivants
alors je voudrais bien que c'est publié
aux éditions théâtrales et je voudrais
dire aussi que c'est le 23 juillet tous
vous commencez vos lectures et
maintenant si vous aimez le théâtre
vivant vous devez aimer les surfers 2
aviez d'orange et que nous sommes allés
voir ce décor de taule c'est la cité des
surfeurs un quartier abandonné squatté
par les marginaux
ici plus personne n'a d'illusions sur la
société dans ce milieu de drogue et de
prostitution
ils sont une poignée arrivée de vagues
la moyenne j'ai perdu de détente j'aime
bien ce travail terminé bien à la plage
les mâles tendance à la débâcle de ma
gueule mais la société raconté par
xavier durringer ne s'arrête pas là il
s'en prend aussi aux politiques alors
slogans mensongers
on y parle de corruption de paparazzi et
des grands de ce monde qui ne sont plus
des références c'est vous la bouche et
le visage de tous aujourd'hui
gorbatchev qui fait de la pub pour les
pizzas et à la télé on voit des choses
absolument incroyable quand je dirais
presque le monde deviendrait une grande
caricature et le théâtre elle a en fait
pour amener à une réalité pour poser des
questions sur son blog la société de
xavier durringer mais pas très belle à
voir
certes on y vit on sy souris mais on y
crie m'associe
surfer serait une farce mais c'est une
farce politique
voilà merci beaucoup monsieur une petite
dernière question à pierre arditi avant
2 avant de vous quitter
entre votre lecture vous et le temps
d'aller un petit peu au spectacle des
dettes dans cette ambiance de d'avignon
qui vous plaît j'imagine ah oui oui je
la connais bien cette ambiance pas
encore parce que je viens de débarquer
mais j'ai bien l'intention d'y pointer
le bout de mon pif justement pour aller
voir un certain nombre d'auteurs ou de
deux voix je ne connais pas ou pas
encore et c'est important car
aujourd'hui en tout cas j'ai envie
d'aller voir berling dans le derby et
c'est important pour vous entre
comédiens entre hauteur de bourg de vous
retrouver de discuter entre vous oui
c'est important c'est important de
savoir qu'on appartient à la même
famille et tout à l'heure j'entendais
berling dire que que le metteur en scène
avait défendu le texte
la parole des acteurs la parole de
l'auteur et puis cette voix des hommes
qui parlent à d'autres hommes
ça me semble ça être l'essentiel de la
mise en scène le reste de la chantilly
on peut aimer la chantilly j'y suis
moins 106 moi je suis absolument certain
que ce spectacle va à l'essentiel mais
aujourd'hui vous savez l'essentiel n'est
pas à la mode
bon merci en tout cas dès le départ être
à la mode c'est d'être moderne
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
et merci à georges dégoût d'avoir
réalisé 7 7 min page spéciale je vous
rappelle les principaux titres de ce
journal le malaise sur le tour de france
des auditions se poursuivent pour le
directeur sportif et le médecin de
l'équipe festina une rousse elle est
suspendue de ses fonctions
provisoirement mais l'équipe elle reste
dans le tour et puis cette formule le
choc de charles pasqua l'ancien ministre
de l'intérieur propose tout simplement
de régulariser tous les sans papiers
déjà connu pour monsieur chevènement
c'est une plaisanterie voilà dans un
instant la météo la météo avec sophie
davant demain dans les 4 vérités à 7h50
emmanuel vanille recevra jean paul
escande spécialiste du dopage
journal et puis à 20 heures vous aurez
bien sûr rendez vous avec béatrice
schönberg vous souhaite une bonne soirée
sur france 2